I actually just started going through
the process of proving this and
it was an awful lot like stuff
that we've already done,
in terms of taking bellman equations
minus other bellman equations.
So let me just jump to the punch line.
So if you push the math all the way
through, what you find is that
all the transitions and
rewards are alpha close to each other,
then the difference in the values that
you get for following the policy is
going to be no more than G over one
minus gamma, where G is that alpha.
That error amount, plus a discounted
version of that error amount,
times the maximum reward that we get for
forever.
Right, so this is actually
the maximum value that you can get.
If you get the maximum reward over and
over and over again.
>> Okay.
>> So, this just gives a quantity.
And it has some properties
that you'd expect,
like the fact that if we estimate
the parameters perfectly and
alpha is zero,
then this is zero plus zero.
And then, this is zero over
one minus gamma, which zero.
So, the two value functions
are actually identical.
But they fall off from each other.
So, if this alpha is something not zero,
some slightly bigger than zero,
then these value functions
are going to be off by a bit more.
So ultimately what we're
going to want is, we want to know
how accurately do we have to
estimate the transition and rewards?
What should alpha be so that the
difference between the value that we get
by running in our simulation of
the model, and the value that we get
running in the actual MDP,
are really small, like epsilon close.
So I think all we need to do, actually,
is solve for alpha, in terms of epsilon,
to be able to see how accurately we need
to do our estimates to make sure that,
ultimately, our values
are going to be close.
>> That makes sense to me.
>> So this is me now solving for Alpha,
and we end up with this expression here,
[SOUND] which says that, that we need
to take the epsilon that we want,
how close we want the values to be,
and then transform it in various ways.
Actually make it a heck of a lot
smaller, and that gives us how accurate
we need the estimate to
the transitions and rewards to be.
So we know that we're going to be
that close in terms of the value.
>> Sure, that's intuitively obvious,
even to the most casual observer.
>> Well, okay,
you're probably being sarcastic.
[LAUGH]
>> Possibly.
>> So it's maybe not completely obvious
but I, you know, I did algebra here so
it's, it's not,
it's not deep but it's not,
it's not intuitively obvious
why it should have this form.
In fact, usually, I don't know.
Epsilons are like one over.
Oh, but I guess we're trying
to define a quantity, alpha,
which is like an epsilon quantity.
So it wouldn't make sense for
it to be a giant number.
It should be a tiny, tiny number.
But, yeah.
No, no, you're right.
It's not completely obvious.
But the point.
The point that I want to make with this
is they're polynomially
related to each other.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Right.
So if we have RMAX, and
one over one minus gamma, and one over
epsilon, then the kind of alpha that we
get out is going to be polynomially
related to the other things.
>> Okay.
>> So that's reassuring.
I mean, if you actually work out what
these numbers are, they're pretty scary.
But, you know, we're, we're trying to
not let ourselves be scared of that.
The important thing though is that
alpha's not really a parameter of RMAX,
the RMAX algorithm.
Right?
What was the parameter that we had
when we talked about the algorithm.
>> [FOREIGN]
>> [LAUGH] [FOREIGN]
>> So, that is to say,
what we want is a parameter that
says how many times do we have to
try a state action pair,
before we are confident that our
estimate of that transition
probability is better than alpha?
So, how are we going to
get that last piece?
How are we going to turn alpha into C?
>> More algebra?
>> Yeah, but specifically,
there's bounds that come into play here.
So now, we've actually turned
it into the same kind of problem
as the bandit problems that
we were talking about, right?
That we need to know, how many times
do we pull a bandit arm before your
estimate in the mean
is sufficiently close?
And that is the Hoeffding bound.
>> Right.
You did say we were going
to use Hoeffding bounds.
>> Yeah, and the union bound.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> We want to simultaneously
make this alpha
close estimate hold across
all state action pairs.
So we need to make the c big enough, so
that the probability that it fails in
any one of them is sufficiently small.
But it really is exactly the same
argument that we did when
we were talking about bandits.
>> Okay.
And, sure.
So, every.
Every state action
pair is like a bandit,
and you have to pull it
a certain number of times.
>> It's like an estimate of an arm,
right, and
we need all the arm estimates
to be accurate if we want
the arm that we eventually
pick to be near the optimal.
>> Right, okay.
No, that makes
>> That, you know?
I can see the analogy.
I can see the metaphor.
I can see the simile.
>> [LAUGH] All right, perfect.
So, okay.
There's one more piece to this story,
and
then I think we're
doing with exploration.
>> Yay,
we'd be done exploring exploration.
That sounded sort of sad.
>> [SOUND]